>> Hi Anita. I'm Helene Gayle. I'm President
and CEO of CARE, an international organization
focusing on eliminating extreme poverty. We
have put, as a focus of our organization on
improving the lives and empowering women and
girls because we know that both women and
girls are disproportionately impacted by poverty,
but also hold the solution for ending extreme
poverty. Because we know when you invest in
women and girls they are real change agents
of their society, but we also know that they
focus on girls, can get lost and that's why
your story Anita, and this panel is so important
because we know that it is by focusing on
girls that you have the best chance of changing
societies and really tapping in to the root
causes of many of the problems that we all
face and are trying to solve. So I am just
so happy to be able to be here and talk about
the value of the "Girl Effect" and why we
all have to do what we can. Do our part from
wherever we are. Wether we're policy makers,
program implementers, advocates, government
officials, all of us have a part to play.
All of us have a role to make this "Girl Effect"
in development come alive and be able to make
what is the best investment for saving humanity
by investing in girls.